we
visit a lot of planets here on what if
but
k2 141b is the most
extreme one yet are you ready to jump on
board this
one-way space shuttle
if you'd rather stay safely earthbound i
want you to take a look
up at the night sky and find the
constellation of aquarius
right there now imagine traveling
202 light years in that direction
and that's where you'd find the hell
planet
what's that stuff falling from the sky
why is this planet so different from
earth
and how did it get that name
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you
traveled to the hell planet
[Music]
lava planets are exoplanets
they're so close to their host stars
that parts of the planet's surfaces have
melted
and their atmospheres are made of
mineral vapor
and k2 141b or
the hell planet as we're calling it is
one of the most
extreme lava planets discovered
but it's not just immensely hot
it's also exceedingly cold
[Music]
there are two sides to the hell planet
the day side
always faces the orange dwarf star that
the planet orbits
since it's so close to its star the
unrelenting light
creates temperatures of up to 3 000
degrees
but the other side of the planet
couldn't be more different
dwelling in constant darkness the night
side of k2 141b
can get as cold as 200 degrees below
zero
why well the hell planet is
gravitationally locked to its star
because it's so close so the planet
doesn't rotate
on its axis as earth does
now that you're here you have two
options you can either view the planet
from a safe distance
or get closer to the action
you want to get closer you say well
alright
here goes since your space shuttle would
burn up in the intense temperature of
the day side
you'd have to land on the night side
after putting on your high-tech space
suit you take a step
out onto the planet's surface you
are now the first person to ever set
foot on
wait wait a second what's that sound
oh no i forgot to tell you
that didn't go well let's back up
you'll need to keep your distance this
time as i was saying
i forgot to tell you that the hell
planet
rains rocks the hot side of the planet
is so extreme that magma can evaporate
that's why the atmosphere is toxic it's
made of sodium
silicon monoxide and silicon dioxide not
the nitrogen and oxygen we breathe on
earth
supersonic winds carry this mineral
vapor
over to the planet's cold side where it
rains down as quartz pebbles and
falls into a magma ocean the magma
ocean is about 100 kilometers deep
and it eventually flows to the hot side
where it evaporates back into the
atmosphere
it's sort of like the water cycle on
earth but deadlier
it's also not as stable the magma
ocean on the cold side of the planet is
slower and
scientists predict that this will cause
the mineral composition to
change over time so the surface and the
atmosphere
will also change all rocky planets
including earth began as molten planets
that
rapidly cooled and solidified studying
the hell planet
could provide scientists with better
insights
into how earth formed so the hell planet
may not always be so hellish
i hope you like it here because it would
take
seven million five hundred and fourteen
thousand four hundred years to travel to
k2141b
so this would be a one-way trip
you wouldn't have enough resources to
make it back to earth
unless it wasn't earth that you traveled
from
maybe you came from another exoplanet
which humans
settled on but
that's a story for another
what if